so how did this come about Sebastian did
you say Dad I sure would like it if
Robert De Niro played me in a movie it
was Unreal that the man said yes because
you just don't think that Robert De Niro
is going to end up playing your father
it's something that is you know it was
like a dream come true so uh when we
wrote the script
um obviously uh Bob was uh can I call
you Bob yeah
um
well look I've said you know Robert
they're like no Bob and then you know I
I I I confront the world that you know
we call people older than you mister
yeah when he said he wanted to do it it
was like you know I called him he don't
believe nothing right I'm like De Niro's
gonna play you he's like yeah right come
on I don't believe it until I see it
um
when you said it yes I said wait a
minute yeah you're right so I say lemon
hold on let me get my hearing aid
because